health care is in the midst of a digital
revolution and it's generating an ocean
of data
there's loads of health data out there
patient records that have been digitized
gene sequences medical images lab tests
and then of course there's the sensors
that we're increasingly wearing on our
bodies whether they're fitbit's or
earbuds or Apple watches or maybe just
your own mobile phone that you carry
around with you now some of the tech
companies that made those devices are
eyeing up the data they're collecting
Microsoft and Walgreens in a seven-year
deal and it includes up to 12 digital
health centers alphabet the owner of
Google has made an offer to acquire
Fitbit these companies have made vast
fortunes from processing managing and
mining data today they're turning those
talents to healthcare but will that make
you feel better
you'd need to record at least 10 finger
movements and combined with those data
that will give you this score this app
is designed to monitor a patient's
Parkinson's disease just by using the
camera on a smartphone this is a test
that traditionally you're doing it in
the healthcare settings in front of a
neurologist it's been created by a tech
startup called meadow pad dan vadet is
its boss with the phone like this I can
measure my resting heart rate I can
measure and do a test for Parkinson a
test for Alzheimer's can we look at some
of the popular the app tracks the
patient symptoms so that doctors know
when to intervene rather than waiting
for the patient to come to them we think
there's a new category in medicine which
is based on all the data that your body
generates and the whole idea and our
focus is to see can we find signatures
that quantify your health quantify
different diseases you might be dealing
with these invisible footprints are cool
digital biomarkers and you're leaving
them wherever you go through watches
wearable technology and smart phones
there are already thousands of
diagnostic and monitoring applications
targeting a host of different conditions
and diseases
Health Care's are all about the data
this digital biomarker category probably
it will have the biggest impact in
medicine because of the amount of data
is going to generate
combined the digital biomarkers produce
big and potentially very valuable
datasets and that's just the tip of the
iceberg factor in the vast volume of
data already generated by healthcare
systems in the daily effort to look
after patients and populations and
there's the potential to improve
outcomes on a far bigger scale there is
a whole bunch of things you can do just
with a much broader and deeper view of a
patient through digital health records
you can pick up medical errors for
example and you can also figure out
which pathways of care are most
efficient you know it's only by
assembling you know lots of patient
health data that you start to see what
spending is useful and what spending
isn't by many health systems what you
find is you know you have pools of
medical data in different places and
it's not until that you link these up
that you can really wring out the power
that they have to kind of give you
really wonderful insights digitizing and
linking this data enables patterns and
trends to be spotted but it's a big job
and the evidence suggests that many
countries have a long way to go
healthcare systems have been quite slow
in using modern technologies to
revolutionize themselves some people say
that there are about ten years behind
other sectors in 2017 the OECD a group
of mostly rich countries judged how
ready its members are for a revolution
in health tech it looked at two factors
technological readiness meaning
digitized records that can already be
used for monitoring and research and
policy the extent to which governments
facilitate the use of data in these
digitized records
some countries like Slovakia have the
technology ready but are held back by
government lagging others like Poland
have more policy in place but less
technology ready and even though many
osed members have a high proportion of
health datasets digitized only a small
percentage of them are regularly linked
with other sources of information take
Singapore although all of its key
national health data sets are available
just under a third are linked making
vast quantities of data redundant the
reason most OECD country health systems
don't clean up their data sets or at
least that they haven't so far is really
that the data that exists in the
healthcare system it's not really there
for this purpose the point of it is to
look after human beings in the moment in
efficiencies in health services and
failure to make full use of digital
technologies mean that rich countries
are wasting up to six hundred billion
dollars a year that's around eight
percent of current health spending and
more than the equivalent of the GDP of
Sweden at a time when all of the oecd
health care systems are struggling under
a burden of increasingly old patients
lower amounts of money flowing into the
system there's just not a lot of money
there to do the kind of digital
reorganization that is needed
enter big tech with its massive
computing power and expertise in data
analytics and it's very keen to offer
its services to overwhelmed health care
systems
Microsoft is providing American
healthcare systems with AI tools to
analyze health data relating to surgery
outcomes and cancer therapies Google is
working with ascension one of the
largest American health firms to create
an online tool so that its doctors can
more easily search patient data and in
the UK Google has been working with the
Royal Free a London Hospital to identify
patients who are most at risk of falling
seriously ill in hospital when big tech
companies work with hospitals you can
start to see the potential for some
really big wins but at the same time
there are also risks just because the
tech company says that it can do amazing
things with your data you know doesn't
mean that it's going to work
health systems really have to kind of
think hard about patient privacy and
security of the data for example Google
got into hot water when the Royal Free
shared patient data with it in a way
that it shouldn't have done this tension
goes beyond big text access to existing
patient data the aspirations of some of
these companies continue to grow fueled
in part by their ability to collect
health data directly from the public
it's now the private sector trying to
show the government how to do it Amazon
finally making that big foray into the
healthcare industry announcing earlier
its partnership with Berkshire Hathaway
and JP Morgan to form a healthcare
company Apple is using the research app
on its iPhone and watch to conduct
medical studies with academic
institutions the ambitions are verily
Google's sister company seemed even
greater its goal is to become the
central repository for health data
worldwide a kind of medical Google Maps
if you think about Google Maps it was an
effort to really understand all of the
roads not just in your backyard but
really in the whole world
and in many ways healthcare has some
similarities we have to understand the
system but also as a patient you have to
understand your health at a very deep
level and so when we think about
projects for example like project
baseline where we're trying to map human
health this is going to be a new ground
truth to understand comprehensive health
data project baseline analyzes health
data to discover clues that can predict
disease creating a research platform
that verily hopes will enhance clinical
care Camillo bossiness is one of its
volunteers paid to undergo a broad range
of tests over a four-year period there
are a lot of reasons why to do this I've
got two children and one of these I've
thought about it if something happens to
me in the next five years then there
will be this real-time log of
information about me this first test is
called the forced vital capacity what
we're measuring is how much air you can
take in and how fast you can blast it
out do you last it out
no keep going keep going don't stop deep
breath in many of these tests will be
familiar to anyone who's had a health
check the difference is what verily does
with the results the date of the company
is collecting clinical behavioral
psychological and even molecular will be
analysed in an effort to build a
comprehensive baseline of good health
[Music]
the state will be anything from genomics
to patients experiences but having this
information hopefully we will do two
main things one it helped us as a
community to create an infrastructure to
actually handle all that data and then
secondarily the idea is to try to look
for signals of changes in health before
disease actually happened
the end result could be an invaluable
asset for Humanity but also a pretty
valuable one to license in the multi
trillion dollar health care market it's
this mix of idealism and opportunity
that makes many people uneasy especially
when the prospect is raised of these
same companies having access to the data
in their own medical records the issue
that all of the tech companies face is
that they're now so big and so prevalent
that they've kind of taken on this
negative scary connotation the idea that
any of them might have my patient data
does not play well with the public a
survey from 2019 looked at how willing
Americans are to share their information
it found that unsurprisingly people are
most happy to share health data with
their doctor but far less willing to
share with pharmaceutical companies or
the government and least of all with
tech companies privacy is contextual
it's about the expectations that the
user has over the data that they provide
and in a healthcare context what it
usually means is that I'm happy to share
this with my doctor but I'm not happy to
share this with advertising companies
that my doctor wants to make a bit of
money on the side from by selling my
patient profile to them health systems
and governments eyeing the benefits of
partnering with big tech have a delicate
balance to strike to reap the rewards
they'll need to ease public fears about
what happens to their data that means
taking the lead to ensure patient
privacy is protected and demanding
greater transparency about the use of
data there are potentially huge rewards
for health systems the welcome
technology companies and they can
improve care they can save lives you can
save money you also need to think about
what happens if tech companies aren't
welcome are the health system's going to
develop this technology for themselves
and if they don't what is the cost in
human life
- those things not happening if you'd
like to find out more about how
technology is transforming healthcare
click on the link opposite that will
take you to a special report from The
Economist where you'll also find some of
the data and research we use to make
this film don't forget to like and
subscribe thanks so much for watching
[Music]